is the story from independent or Trump
class claimed he would end the Russia
War if he was President the former
president described the situation as a
disaster if I were president and I say
this I will end the war and one day
would take 24 hours I know zelinski well
I know Putin well I would get that ended
in a period of 24 hours it would be easy
the deal would be easy which do you
agree with 100 tell me what Trump's
gonna go to Putin and say we are ending
all support for the ukrainians in this
in this matter
what here are the concessions we're
going to make I imagine what people need
to understand about what this means
Trump likely hands over Don bass to to
Russia hands over Sebastopol Crimea to
Russia confirmed done end of story the
the the the history of what's going on
in this region is very very complicated
the average person probably doesn't know
and I can only go so far back there's
something called the cutter turkey
pipeline back in 2009 the CIA intended
to oust the Assad regime uh because they
would not allow us to build a natural
gas pipeline through Syria turkey into
Europe to offset Russia's natural gas
Monopoly in Ukraine so what ends up
happening is
Western Powers go to Syria say hey we
want to build this pipeline it's going
to go through Sierra through turkey they
say no explicitly we are allied with
Russia and that would be against their
interests
what then happens is I think it was Iran
and uh and Russia say let's build our
own version of this pipeline tapping the
same natural gas source and running it
up bolstering our natural gas control
into Europe
there's a lot of reasons for why the the
West was upset about it one of them is
that the the point of the EU and the
reason they want cheap energy is so they
can economic they can develop
economically faster to compete with
China
when they were looking at this massive
dependence on high-cost Russian natural
gas and an inability to get any
alternatives into Europe they said let's
end Syria
fortunately for the West a civil war
just happened to have broken out you
know for whatever reason and we were on
the opposite side of that Isis then
emerges Syria destabilizes how very
convenient Joe Biden a form uh Joe
Biden's son becomes a board member at an
energy company in Ukraine surprise
surprise also a former CIA director is
also on the board of barisma Joe Biden
then goes to Ukraine and tells the
president if you don't fire the
prosecutor Victor shock and you're not
getting a billion dollars in loan
guarantees which is illegal I might add
the vice president does not have the
authority to stop congressionally
approved loan guarantees to another
country but hey they impeach Donald
Trump for that but you know okay that
Joe Biden did it I think the the
principal reason of what's Happening
Here is we Russia is impeding our
ability to expand in Europe economically
nordstream 2 for instance who blew that
up likely uh I think what it is maybe
sales probably I think they're saying it
was CIA assisted it was like uh the
British perhaps um I got to follow they
don't have a clear answer as I think but
it's not that's stupid blowing up their
own pipeline yeah that's right
ridiculous but all of this is it's very
obvious that we have a dependence on
Russian gas we're trying to resist and
so what happens with Ukraine NATO's been
expanding into Eastern Europe for a very
very long time Estonia Latvia on the
border of Russia Russia has its only
warm water port in savastapol Crimea
which gives them access to the Black Sea
to the Mediterranean and then outward a
lot of trade goes through there and then
what happens the euromidan protests
emerge and the people of Ukraine are now
split pro-russia pro-eu most of them
leaning towards pro-eu that's my per
that's what I've seen from the data and
in my personal experience having been on
the ground when that was happening and
talking to the people of Kiev even
random people saying we don't trust
Russia we know the history of the Soviet
Union the holiday more we want to be
with the EU
so when Russia sees that happening what
people need to understand is that uh
shouted Dave Smith Russia did not in the
immediate invade quote unquote this is
back in I think 2014. they were already
in Crimea in Sebastopol they simply
walked out of the base and said hey
we're here now you can argue the
referendum was fake and all that but
what do you think Russia is going to do
if NATO seeks to expand into a country
and the EU when that's their only warm
water port and access to the Black Sea I
mean fight that's fine it's fight time
that's it so you can argue that Russia
started the fight you can argue and
people say no NATO did people say no
Russia did I'm like dude if if Russia
started putting troops in Mexico and
then threatened to cut off the U.S
access in the Gulf the U.S is going to
beat them fighting words yep and then
especially if if more importantly if
Russia already controlled a large
portion of the Border like NATO controls
you know NATO was in Estonia and Latvia
Russia is already angry about this
it's it you it doesn't matter who you
blame it matters a fight will happen and
that's where we are I think Trump goes
in negotiates it pisses off uh Ukraine
it pisses off Russia but it ends the
fight
example forgets but uh so then if Trump
doesn't
man Trump doesn't win do you think war
of Russia is inevitable with the way
that things were going on with Russia I
I agree but I'm saying it's already on
the ground 100 the the first we got the
story from The Intercept they kept
denying it it's um it's not it's not
like it's the most people in the world I
think it's a special force it's NATO
Special Forces and several dozen yeah uh
but now it's been it's been leaked it's
it's true
the US is providing intelligence to you
here's what's happening right yo if if
you and your neighbor are fighting with
each other and then I walk up to you and
I hand you a big old pile of rocks and I
tell you where to throw them do you
think your neighbor is gonna be like
that guy's not involved at all he's
gonna be like this dude is the one so
we're arming Ukraine we're telling them
where to shoot their missiles yeah the
United States provided the Intel to
Ukraine to sink the Black Sea Flagship
of Russia the idea that Russia as Putin
is going man how is how is Ukraine
beating us it's absurd Putin is saying
NATO is at war with us using the
ukrainians as cannon fodder American
citizens as quote unquote volunteers
military trained and armed are on the
ground in in it's it's the most
ridiculous thing in the world but people
live in this reality where because
there's no formal declaration that means
United States veteran troops armed by
the United States
that means we're not actually at War
like I'm sorry dude you can't have PM
private military contractors quote
unquote volunteers from the United
States and Western countries fighting a
war funded by you armed by you and then
expect to believe Russia thinks they're
not fighting you like Russia and Russian
television outright said we are at war
with NATO so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]